Speaker 1: Let's go next to Alex from Des
Moines, Iowa. Alex, you're on the air.
Speaker 3: Hey, David, thanks for having me. I
have been shocked, as I imagine you are, at the
amount of media coverage that has not included
George Bush's name. Yes, repeatedly regarding
Afghanistan. Yes. And I'm kind of stunned and
I'm wondering if you see it this way as well.
I've been thinking about all the events that
have unfolded, and I'm left with this impression,
which is we got into this mess. Was George Bush
accomplished the one clear goal that we had?
And then it seems every president there left after
were. Well, to be fair, George Bush didn't have an
accomplishment. Obviously, we had to wait until
Obama was president to get that accomplishment
and then from that point forward, no one knew
what to do. I have a hard time blaming Biden
or for even that matter, Trump in this case
and credit where it's due. I feel like Trump
deserves credit for starting this process, even
if he's lying now and turning around and saying,
well, I would have done it differently, which was
not the case. His plan was to pull out on May 1st.
Speaker 1: I basically agree with this. Yeah, I
basically agree with you. And as I outlined in
a segment on Wednesday about this, this was going
to happen. This was going to become chaotic.
And regardless of when this was done, the one
criticism you could make is that there should
have been more care, one preparing for
the demand for people fleeing the country
and determining what our responsibility
will be as far as that goes. And number two,
getting our people out as well. There could have
been more time and care spent on that. But the
idea that Trump would have done it in some perfect
way where this wouldn't have happened or whatever,
the part of the reason we've been, there's a lot
of reasons we've been there so long. One of them
is just the inertia of one. Once you're doing
something, it takes a lot to get you to change
what you're doing. Contractors were making a ton
of money. It was seen as sort of like, yeah, OK,
even if this is hanging by a thread and we have
to be there in order to keep it that way, we sort
of prefer that to some degree. But then there's a
whole bunch of different things that that we can
say about it. But I basically agree with you to
the extent that Trump planned to do this, he gets
credit for it. It would have imploded in the same
way Biden made a definitive statement and said,
we're getting out, no question whatsoever.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I just I'll reiterate,
I think all of the media should be indicted
on charges of not bringing up George Bush
on a story that must involve Bush.
Speaker 1: Yeah, about that. Let me
say something. So about that I made an analogy
to like a dental problem earlier this week. I'll
make another analogy to that. If you go and you
buy a car brand new from a manufacturer and the
car is an absolute and complete disaster, you put
you shifted into first gear and it goes backwards
and you press the brakes and the horn goes off
and stuff like that. And then you bring it to a
mechanic. And the mechanic fixes like two of the
six issues. But you've still got four issues. And
so now you're mad at that mechanic and then
you bring it to another mechanic and they
fix one issue. You can talk about the things the
mechanics failed to fix, but it's the manufacturer
that gave you the disastrous car. And in this
situation, that that manufacturer is George Bush.
And I talked about him in my segment on Wednesday.
He is not getting the attention he deserves when
it comes to this disaster.
Speaker 3:
Right, thanks. All right, thank you.
Speaker 1: Very good.